blackout on June 12 2023 over 8 000
subreddits decided to go completely dark
users couldn't join edit or even view
any of the content on these subreddits
instead they were met with messages like
this CFL has gone private in protest
against where it's exorbitant new API
pricing the community will not Grant
access requests during the protest
please do not message asking to be added
to oh oops definitely did not do that
clearly I was not aware of what was
going on but like hundreds of millions
of other users I became aware of the
situation quite quickly and some of the
biggest communities were going down this
included r slash all with 34 million
members r slash music with 32 million
members and r slash futurology with 18
million members just to name a few
at first this was seen as one of the
most effective online protests we've
seen as it not only spread the word but
it also made Reddit feel the pain as
they weren't earning ad revenue from the
subreddits but almost as quickly as the
protests to gained steam it
disappeared what did Reddit do you ask
well the answer is nothing they just
stood their ground and waited and the
things have somehow magically returned
to normal so join me as we take a deep
dive into one of the biggest online
protests we've seen and why it utterly
failed
[Music]
foreign
so what's the big deal anyway why are
hundreds of millions of users not able
to see cat pics and memes well it all
boils down to the fact that Reddit sucks
not as a platform though some would
argue that as well but as a business
we've talked extensively on this channel
about companies prioritizing growth and
influence over profits but Reddit is
unlike anything else we've seen the
company has been around for nearly 20
years and has 1.6 billion monthly active
users put another way it's the 19th most
visited website on the planet and the
12th most visited website in the US but
despite this Reddit is somehow not only
not profitable but they don't pull in
any money in fact Reddit is estimated to
only pull in a mere 510 million dollars
per year which given their use account
is absolute garbage I mean they're
literally making two and a half cents
per user per month for perspective their
own paid tier costs six dollars per
month so we're talking about a revenue
difference of nearly 200x between the
average user and a paying user but not
only do they pull in no money they also
spend a bunch of money maintaining a
platform with a billion plus users is
not cheap by any means you need massive
server rooms databases and a lot of tech
infrastructure in general you also need
a bunch of people to maintain all this
and being headquartered in San Francisco
Reddit has become accustomed to insane
compensation packages of half a million
dollars for software Engineers which is
great for the engineers but once again
garbage for the business
virtually no money coming in but
exorbitant amounts going out to be
honest I have no idea how VCS have put
up with Red's financials for so long but
it looks like they're finally pulling it
back in fact Reddit is planning on
ipoing later this year likely hoping
that the public markets are more
tolerant of their losses but before
doing that they wanted to patch things
up and to make the business seem as
viable as possible likely the easiest
way to do this would have been to crack
down on an ad block I don't have any
stats for this but I'd wager that the
vast majority of editors use Adblock
given that they tend to be more tech
savvy and rebellious in general so
eliminating Adblock itself might
increase the revenue by multiple fold
and I'm sure they consider that but it
looks like they decided against it
likely if you're in public backlash
another easy solution would have been to
jack up prices on their premium
subscriptions but then again Netflix's
brand favorability dropped to 11 after
doing this same thing with the IPL
coming up Reddit really couldn't risk
anything that would harm their brand
image what they needed was a revenue
stream that no one would bat an eye
about something that no one would even
notice like API usage surely price hikes
for API usage would go completely
unnoticed oh how wrong they were
late April Reddit announced that they
would start charging for API usage for
the first time the price 24 cents per
1000 API calls wait hold up what even
our API calls well API calls are what
you use to integrate various portions of
Reddit into your own website or app API
calls are not unique to Reddit likely
the most popular apis are Google apis
for example if you go onto a
restaurant's website and see an
interactive map showing you where the
restaurant is located that website is
most likely using Google's Map API
similarly if you're filling out a
billing or shipping address and you see
autocomplete results that website is
most likely using Google's places API
every time a user interacts with the map
or uses the autocomplete feature an API
call is being made to Google and these
websites are charged based on how many
API calls they make every month for
dynamic Maps Google charges seven
dollars per 1000 requests and for
autocomplete Google charges 2.83 cents
per 1000 requests
considering this reddit's 24 cents per
1000 to calls is really not out of the
ordinary not to mention but it is
offering an extremely generous free tier
in fact you can make up to 100 calls per
minute completely for free so
theoretically you can make up to 4.3
million calls per month for absolutely
no cost but then what's the issue well
the issue is that it used to be free
regardless of scale meaning that several
substantial businesses have been built
around this free idea one such a
business is Apollo Apollo is an IOS app
that's basically a skin for Reddit
essentially it uses a bunch of Reddit
apis to recreate the entire Reddit
experience but with a completely new UI
which a lot of people prefer in fact the
app has nearly a million daily active
users but here's the problem apps like
Apollo don't show Reddit ads because I
mean what's in it for them this means
that Reddit is essentially having to
support all of these users completely
for free even worse apps like Apollo are
able to make money by charging users a
premium subscription fee none of which
goes to Reddit so these businesses
basically have no expenses all of the
backend infrastructure is maintained and
paid for by Reddit and all the front end
runs on iPhones so the only expense for
these businesses is the cost of
front-end development and given that
most of these apps were built by a
single developer or a small team this is
also a non-expense so basically
everything that people are going to pay
for these apps is pure profit of course
after the Apple tax but while this adds
up to a lot of money on an individual
basis it's not a lot to run an actual
business of their scale for example
let's assume that about 10 of Apollo's
user base actually pays for the app this
would translate to approximately a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars per
month which is again great as an
individual but as a business with 900
000 active users making 7 billion API
calls per month it's nothing and that's
the problem
[Music]
the core of the Reddit protest is that
the API pricing is simply way too high
and on the surface this indeed seems to
be the case for a poly to continue
operations they would have to pay Reddit
1.7 million dollars per month or 20
million dollars per year that's a crazy
amount right 24 cents per 1000 requests
must be unreasonable but here's the deal
Apollo was also making a crazy amount of
requests they're literally making 7
billion requests per month that
translates to nearly 8 000 requests per
user per month that's why it's so
expensive it's because the API is being
used in a way that it's not meant to be
used here's an example of how apis are
normally used maybe you can integrate a
Twitter post into an article this would
only cost a mere fifth of a penny per
user according to Red's pricing a super
cheap fear but apps like Apollo aren't
just importing one post they're trying
to import the entire platform of Reddit
and that's why it adds up to 2.50 per
user per month and if you're still not
convinced think about this even if
Reddit decreased their pricing by 10x
down to 2.4 cents per 1000 calls that
would still cost 170 000 per month for
Apollo which would still likely be
unsustainable
so is this a case of Reddit implementing
python that's magnitude's higher than it
should be or is it the case of apps like
Apollo only being viable if reddit's
apis are virtually free I'll let you be
the judge of that feel free to post your
thoughts down below but anyway much of
the user basis of Apollo redplant sync
and reddit is fun naturally felt that it
was Red's fault in the given that this
encompasses much of reddit's most
dedicated user base a lot of them knew
mods and were mods themselves so it
didn't take long for them to join forces
and stage one of the largest online
protests we've seen dubbed red dark they
would essentially make 8 000 of the most
popular subreds in the world private
starting on June 12 2023 and let's just
say this definitely made a scene almost
overnight all Reddit users became aware
of the protest against Reddit and with
how quickly drama spreads it wasn't long
until people who never even used Reddit
also knew about it and to given that
most people naturally have a tendency to
side with the Underdog they immediately
turned on Reddit and especially Reddit
CEO Steve Hoffman Steve was under a lot
of fire but he didn't budge on red
stance whatsoever the bottom line was
Reddit needs to be a self-sustaining
business and to do that we can no longer
subsidize commercial entities that
require large-scale data use Reddit had
made their position clearer but this
only infuriated the community even more
they were going to band together and
protest for as long as it took wait
never mind just 48 hours later most of
these subreddits would be back up
you're probably asking it what happened
why did the protest die down so quickly
well a lot of people point to The
Limited blackout period of 48 Hours you
see it in order to get as many mods and
subreddits on board the organizers of
red dark only asked for a 48 hour
blackout period further protesting would
be up to the discretion of the mods so
people say that if the mods were more
committed the protest would have been
more effective which may have been true
but I don't think it would have changed
the end result all that much the bottom
line is that the average redditor simply
did not care about the protest more than
simply saying oh wow Reddit is bad now
where are my cat memes and Mr Robot
discussion threats I know that sounds
stupid but that's the reality only 1
million people use Apollo over a billion
people use Reddit so we're talking about
0.1 percent of the user base so while
red dark was able to spread awareness
about their campaign and even get people
to agree with the ideological effort
they were not able to get people to
sacrifice for the cause and that was
really where it all fell apart the idea
of any protest is that you sacrifice
things in the short term to make things
better over the long term the company
Reddit clearly understood this as that
was exactly what they were doing by
protesting the protest they were
essentially sacrificing short-term ad
revenue and brand reputation for
long-term profitability now I do want to
mention that a good amount of subreddits
are still protesting but this is
increasingly becoming the minority
especially with pressure mounting
against mods both from the community and
from Reddit and unfortunately it looks
like services like Apollo will indeed be
closing down at the end of June when the
pricing changes go into effect after
which protesting becomes virtually
useless another company that might be
worth protesting against is Goodwill
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one